good morning everybody um
sorry we can't be face-to-face but in
the age of covet we're taking advantage
of uh
distance learning technology to
[Music]
present some of the research going on in
my laboratory
my name is dr robert allen i'm a
professor of forensic science
at in the school of forensic sciences at
oklahoma state university center for
health sciences in tulsa oklahoma
i am by trade a forensic geneticist
and um what i'm going to talk to you
about today
is some of the work that we have been
doing that is relevant to the concept of
time
so let me just get
things going here so the investigation
of a crime by a forensic scientist
usually involves
providing answers to four basic
questions
that allow uh for the reconstruction
of a crime and the events that
transpired leading to a crime
and ultimately the four questions are
who what where and when
and if you can answer these four
questions you can often identify the
perpetrator of a crime
and uh subject to them to prosecution
thereby maintaining public safety
so the question of who at least in 2020
is an answer that is readily obtained
through the analysis
of dna looking at variability in our dna
and thus tracing the source of
biological samples associated with a
crime
back to the person who participated or
perhaps was responsible for the crime
question of what in terms of a forensic
scientist world
is usually involved with identifying
tissues or body fluid stains that are
recovered as
evidence from a crime scene
and um we now have technologies that are
much like the home pregnancy test
technology immunodiffusion
chromatography
with the use of monoclonal antibodies
that allow you to identify
um semen blood saliva
even urine sweat
all based upon protein components that
are present
in those body fluids that will react
with highly specific
antibodies we also can identify
quite often a particular body fluid
through microscopy
understanding the morphology of cell
types that
compose a particular tissue that may be
present
in that evidentiary sample and the
newest
approach on the block these days is
messenger rna profiling
exploiting the tissue specific
collection
of messenger rnas that are present in
in cells comprising a tissue or a body
fluid
and those patterns of gene expression
can be exploited to identify that
particular tissue type
the question of where is is quite often
self-evident is by
looking at the crime scene of all these
questions the question of when
is the one for which we have the fewest
tools
and yet questions of when are often
quite quite important in understanding
the events that led to a crime and so
that's really where
the research i'm going to talk about
today originates
back in 2014 a phd student in my
laboratory at the time kate weinbrecht
and i decided that it would be
interesting to see if we could estimate
the age
of biological material recovered as
evidence
from a crime scene and
our approach to beginning this project
involved the use of next generation
sequencing
of all the rna transcripts in blood
semen saliva and vaginal secretions
that had been stored for varying lengths
of time in the laboratory
and the question was can we follow
the decomposition or the degradation
of rnas messenger rnas in these body
fluid stains dried body fluid stains
um as they are stored over long periods
of time
up to a year in this case uh in the
laboratory
so through the use of rna sequencing we
could look at
all the rnas that were present and based
upon
um the sequence data which is an
indirect
reflection of the abundance of
particular
transcripts in these stains
we could ask whether or not rnas
disappeared from the transcriptome
with in a predictable fashion and if so
do they disappear in a way that could be
used sort of as a biological block
and what we found was yes indeed rnas do
disappear
from the transcription of dried body
fluid stains
and so we wanted to devise
using this rna sequencing data
quantitative polymerase chain reaction
assays which are much cheaper much more
straightforward
to perform in a forensic laboratory and
interestingly enough in looking at the
rna sequencing data
we discovered that the sequencing read
depth which is an indirect uh measure
of abundance um that the re-depth
of the five-prime end of the messenger
rna disappeared at a faster rate
than the re-depth at the three-prime end
of that message
so and data for this is is shown
here in this slide down in the bottom
left and you can see these histograms
the height of which reflects how many
times
each of the nucleotides in that region
in this case
beta actin messenger rna how many times
each of those nucleotides is actually
sequenced
in that reaction so the higher the peaks
in the histogram
the deeper uh the larger the number of
breeds and you can see at time
zero you have at about
the same peak heights if you will from
the five prime end of the message which
is on the right
right side of the right most uh
series of peaks in the histogram versus
the three prime end which
is the left most and after 180 days
clearly
the five prime end has decreased so this
led to the design of the qpcr
assay where we actually studied the
abundance of the
ends of single transcripts
rather than quantify a transcript that
changes
in abundance against one that is
presumably stable a housekeeping gene or
something
which is sort of the normal way people
quantify the abundance
of transcripts or any
sort of dna any nucleic acid that is
changing with crime
so this led to the development of an
assay
a qpcr assay in which we quantify the
five prime
end of a messenger rna transcript say
the first
70 to 90 base pairs from the five prime
end
versus another transcript of 75 to 90
bases
from the three prime end of the
transcript the notion being that as it
degrades
these fragments would remain inside
these derived stains
and would continue to decrease in
abundance as the blood stain
began to decompose so as these curves
as you can see in these curves they uh
this is four different transcripts
present in blood stains
lgal s2 clc
s100 a12 down in the lower left and
beta2 microglobulin
if you're at all familiar with
[Music]
rna quantitation
beta beta2 microglobulin is is a message
that is present in virtually all tissues
it produces a protein that associates
with this compatibility antigens and
other membrane
other membrane components much like
associates with this compatibility
antigens at least
much like immunoglobulin light chains
associated with
associated with immunoglobulin heavy
chains in
in antibody molecules so as these curves
increase going from left to right the
uh abundance of five prime end
of these transcripts is is disappearing
from the transcriptome and as the curve
goes up and then levels off
the abundance of five prime uh
into the transcripts is below the limit
of detection
for um for our quantitative
pcr platform so this work was published
by dr june foo and myself in 2019
and uh it allowed us a very sensitive
and reliable we felt approach to
quantifying
the abundance of rnas in dried
evidentiary
type samples and blood stains certainly
in this case
and so to test this hypothesis
we created some stains so we knew what
their age was
we gave these things to a technologist
instead
as unknowns and then using these curves
for in particular s 100 a 12 for example
we can plot the delta c q value of our
unknown
on this curve and extrapolate and make
an estimate
of sample age so when we did that
here's results for eight stains and
we're
we've got the actual age on the left and
then going to the right
the estimates made with the lgal
transcript the clc transcript the s100
transcript
and beta-2 microglobulin
b2m of course is uh uh only good for
very short periods if you recall
the curve it degrades very quickly from
the five prime end
and then levels out after about
six to eight weeks of incubation and
these
stains by the way were stored in the
laboratory in the dark
under controlled conditions but uh the
point i want to make here especially
with the s100
812 transcript is you get
very good estimates of sample age
based upon a lot of data that i won't
actually talk about today
but statistical analysis of
differences in delta cq values for
stains of differing age
we ultimately concluded in from this
work
that the window of accuracy for any
estimates for samples up to a year
of storage was about two to four weeks
for the first six months
in about four to six weeks for um
six months to one year probably even
six months to 18 months or two years
again using the s-100 transcript
we felt we had a really
had made a great deal of progress in
being able to estimate the age
of at least blood stains recovered from
crime scene
so as i said all of the storage here in
the study i've talked about today today
this far
is stains blood stains dry blood stains
stored
at room temperature in a controlled
environment however that's not really
very real world
so the next phase of the project was
designed
to try and evaluate the effects of
environmental conditions
on the rate of rna degradation in blood
stains
because evidence sometimes may be found
in the trunk of a car
parked in the hot sun or may be
found in a very cold environment and all
our environments in between
so we wanted to look at the effect of
degradation
first challenge though was to create a
stable environment
in which we could control relative
humidity
and temperature so the humidity part
was initially kind of a challenge until
i stumbled on to a publication from
the early 1970s in the microbiology
literature
where uh investigators were trying to
assess the effects of relative humidity
on the growth of bacteria and
in this one paper i discovered the
the take home lesson for from that
publication at least for me
was that the discovery that if you
have a sealed environmental chamber
containing
a beaker with a solution of a saturated
salt
you can create a relative humidity
um defined percentage so
for example if you have a sealed chamber
with saturated
sodium chloride at equilibrium you will
get a relative humidity of 75
really not terribly influenced by
temperature
magnesium chloride about 35 and lithium
chloride about 10
relative humidity so here are pictures
of
three of our humidity chambers you can
see they contain blood stains that have
been
dried and deposited on bloodstained
cards
and then there's a big card that we were
that we found
from scientific supply house that sort
of gives you a
ballpark range of what the relative
humidity is
inside these chambers um sort of like ph
paper and you can see the one on the far
left has a lot of pink
in that line indicating that the
humidity is high
about 70 to 80 percent the one in the
middle
is the magnesium chloride pink only goes
up about halfway
and the one on the far right is lithium
chloride
which shows very virtually no pink at
all
and these the increments on that scale
are increments of 10 relative humidity
once we get these jars set up we can
then
put them in 37 degree incubators or
leave them at room temperature or put
them in a four degree refrigerator
so ultimately we ended up with nine
different environmental storage
conditions
so the experiment was as follows we
prepared blood stains on collection
cards
and then a group of these stains was
stored in one of nine different
environments
three relative humidities uh and three
temperatures at selected times
rna is extracted from duplicate stains
initially and then at 1 2 4 8 16 or 24
weeks
of storage in that condition
when a time point is reached the
the chamber would have to be open uh
bloodstained card taken out quickly
excise the stain replace
the card with the remaining stains back
in the chamber reseal it
and then put it back in its storage
temperature so there was a brief
interruption
of the environment within
within the chambers but it was probably
reestablished within
four to six hours so at each of the time
points would extract total rna
reverse transcribe it into complementary
dna
using oligodt and random primers
and then quantify
the abundance of the five prime and
three prime ends
of these three transcripts using our
rqtcr assay and the question was
can we follow or can we notice any
effect
of temperature and our relative humidity
on rna degradation rate
so here are three of our
storage conditions in terms of
temperature
37 degrees 20 degrees and 4 degrees
and then the colored curves on
in each of these panels represent the
relative humidity and i've got them
listed here
in in trying to consider this data and
digest this data
one wants to try and have
a description of an environmental
condition
that's defined by a single mathematical
value
um so in thinking about
this problem uh what came to mind was
the use of a heat index
value and a heat index value if you
watch your weather
especially in the summertime weatherman
will often give you a combined
[Music]
value a value that combines both
temperature and relative humidity into a
single number
and so we're exploring that right now as
our approach to
uh consider combine both humidity
and temperature into a single single
entity
anyway take home lesson from from this
study is that
both heat and humidity contribute to an
accelerated rate
of rna degradation uh the most severe
and most rapid rate of rna degradation
occurs
at 37 degrees and 75 excuse me a minute
that's going to see 37 degrees and 75
relative humidity you can see that uh
the rate
of degradation of the five prime min of
the s100 812 message
um it increases very very quickly and
actually
levels off after only about four weeks
of storage
whereas at 20 degrees and 35
humidity the conditions um
sort of reflecting what we had in the
laboratory
you can the curve is still increasing
out to
six months of storage pretty much like
we saw uh
previously in in our studies with
with bloodstains initially so
the interesting thing here is that at
four degrees uh degradation almost halts
completely you can see a little bit of
increase
in the delta cq value at four degrees
and seventy-five percent related
humidity
uh but at four degrees and ten percent
relative humidity things are
uh virtually stable over an entire
six-month storage period
so for any of you in in the listening
world
that are studying rna
in dried evidentiary type samples
the take home lesson is that once you
collect your sample from a scene store
to four degrees
in a dry environment to preserve the
integrity
of those transcripts for long periods
so how do we factor all of this
environmental effect into an algorithm
that will allow us to continue to
estimate the age of the stain
well we chose to
have chosen we haven't gotten there yet
we've chosen to start
off by comparing degradation rate
constants and the degradation
rate constant in in this discussion is
basically
how long it's the maximum delta cq value
that is achieved
during uh storage all right
so when it gets to when the curve gets
to its highest value
the delta c value there minus the delta
cq value at time
0 divided by the amount of storage time
it takes to get to that maximal value
and so if we compare these rate
constants
if we control for temperature and vary
uh do comparisons or rate constants for
different humidities
or control for relative humidity and
assess the effects of different
temperatures
it's the take-home lesson from from all
of this work
is that um if you compare
at a at a single temperature 75
humidity versus 35 humidity you get
about a two to three-fold increase
in the degradation rate at the higher
value
likewise if you
have a single humidity and compare the
effective temperature
again it's about a two to three-fold
increase in the rate of degradation
of these transcripts
at a higher temperature so
we're still dealing with
evaluating this data to figure a way
to incorporate it into
as i said some sort of algorithm that
retains
the accuracy in estimating the age of a
staying
clearly you can get the environmental
conditions
from the national weather
organization
[Music]
the cycling up and down of temperature
and up and down of humidity
uh is another variable that we're going
to have to try and
and figure uh incorporate into our
algorithm
but um that that's where we're going
in the future now another interesting
fact is that once degradation starts
if you shift the sample from a high
temperature high humidity
sort of the blue line here in this curve
for the s 1812 transcript again
if you incubate it at 37 degrees and 75
humidity and then at some point shift
that environment to four degrees in a
dry
dry dry environment you can shut down
degradation
so it is reversible in the sense that
you can
promote degradation or [ __ ] or
stop degradation altogether just by
and it happens fairly quickly
[Music]
once you make once you make that
temperature shift to the more stable
environment
degradation halts which to me suggests
that it may be
a chemical process and is involved here
in degradation as opposed to enzymatic
so temperature and environment
another part of the environment is the
substrate that
a body fluid stain resides on or is
deposited on
so we wanted to assess the effect of the
substrate as well
and um substrates can include clothing
uh or surfaces metal ceramic wood
plastic
even carpet and so we created stains
on blood stains on all of these
different substrates
and then stored them for periods of up
to six months
in the laboratory again under
under dark conditions
the results of that study i'm just going
to show you a couple of
um a couple of surfaces which include
carpet
and denim and the take-home lesson from
all of our substrate studies
is that there really is no effect on the
rate of rna degradation
uh depending upon the surface when
compared against
blood stains created with spain carbs
that we're using sort of as our control
so the effect of
the substrate is not very significant
it really doesn't have much of an effect
on the rate of rna regulation which is
good
because that would be if it did have an
effect that would be a further
complicator or distractor
in trying to develop an algorithm with
which to estimate time
well the newest thing where we the
newest question we've asked
is if we can estimate what day
a stain was created on can we estimate
the time of day
a staying was created and
we thought that the way perhaps to
investigate this question was to exploit
rhythmic changes in gene expression that
are
associated with the circadian rhythm and
there's a tremendous amount of
literature
out there describing genes whose
expression seems to vary
over the daily cycle and so our approach
was to
create blood stains and to assess the
abundance
of messenger rnas transcribed from these
genes
over the 24-hour daily cycle
so the experiment was somehow we managed
to recruit a large number of volunteers
who are willing to prick their finger
create a blood stain
on a collection card every four hours
around the clock and we had
i want to say 20 to 30 males
of all different ages and about the same
number of females
who were uh participating who were
willing to volunteer for this study
so once we create a stain
at a select time during the day that
staying within
uh one to two days would be transferred
back to the laboratory
rna extracted from it cdna prepared
and then quantification of the
individual
transcripts originating from genes
associated with a circadian rhythm
would be quantified using ppcr in this
particular
set of experiments we developed qpcr
primers that targeted the middle
of each of these transcripts because
from all of our previous research
we knew that that was the most stable
part
of a messenger rna was the least
likely to be degraded during that two
hours of
storage or
that the time between the stain was
created in the timing
that if the rna was extracted so we got
all this data we analyzed it by sex
whether it's male or female
also by age and tenure increments from
uh 20 to 60 years of age
and interestingly here's some of the
data
that was produced and we had
most of the transcripts that we looked
at
yielded results that either were
unchanging
over a 24-hour period or
produce data very much akin to what you
see
in um the top right panel there for the
per
three transcript and nails huge error
bars
now it's important for you to know that
these error bars
do not reflect technical variability
in our qpcr assay rather
these error bars reflect biological
variability
among the 20 odd males that
were tested so
it's kind of interesting that there's
such widely varying
levels of gene expression four genes
that
are have been suggested to be associated
with the circadian rhythm
that in males for this particular gene
the rhythm is all over the place
however if you look at that same
transcript in females
you see fairly tight variability in the
time points and um the data
for uh cpu values from
noon to the evening on the right side of
that
that curve are significantly different
from the cpu values on the left side of
that panel
so it would be possible using this
marker in a female blood stain
to distinguish whether it was if that
blood stain was created in
the afternoon or in the evening
or early morning likewise another
transcript of tpoh which is
tyrosine metabolizing enzyme that
ultimately
ends up um involved in the production of
melatonin
which of course is is typically high in
in the evenings when you get sleepy
again
those are statistically significant
differences in cpu values
from the early evening 10 11 o'clock
versus the early morning
so we're not where we need to be yet
we're still looking at
uh additional transcripts that seem to
show
cyclic variation in uh abundance inside
blood stains
but we feel that at least proof of
concept here
if we have a whole lot of these markers
that we can
analyze in a test
that we may be able to
discriminate when during the day within
a couple of hours
a stain was created so that's where we
are
right now i want to acknowledge the
people in my laboratory that have been
contributed to the studies that i talked
about today
and to emphasize once again
that time is an important concept to the
forensic scientist
and um ultimately
we hope that from a single body fluid
stain recovered from a crime scene
we can determine who's it it we can
determine what it is whose it is and
when it was deposited
and all of those questions are going to
be very relevant to
our investigation of the crime so thanks
for your attention
i will take any questions i guess by
email after those of you in the audience
think about what i've said today and
i'll do my best to try and answer them
thank you very much